i've got grammys you've got formula one
but we both have pizza oh yes yeah you
can't disagree on beef absolutely as you
know it has come down to our final four
of our pizza bracket challenge so we're
giving you a look at the remaining
restaurants before we had luciano's
earlier this
week and now giordano's over on
charleston jesse ibarra is the general
manager at the boca park location jesse
good morning to you i see
a an enormous pizza in front of you good
morning to you sir
good morning how you guys doing this
morning
doing good of course giordano's you make
your your deep dish chicago pizza uh
how many calories you're talking about
here how how healthy is it oh you can't
ask that
trust me we
we really don't want to talk about
health it's just more talk about how
delicious this is
i love deep dish that to me is is my
favorite it's got so much taste your
pizza is like i love it when you cut it
and there's just cheese cheese all over
yeah
oh god yeah we have erica here from our
uh location out of the strip she's the
general manager out there and she's
about to do a cheese pull for us
wonderful pizza let's see it so we can
go ahead yeah here we go
there you go
look at that all fresh cheese some of
the best ingredients we have here in
town
we use some of the most precious
tomatoes and everything so you guys got
to come down and try this pizza out man
all right so look and i'm standing next
to my lead cook too good deal jesse joe
a quick question though jesse uh you
know deep dish is so different than like
your thin crust style your new york
style pizza
look at the cheese i love this i love
every second of this you can keep going
guys
what is the most uh challenging part
about getting a deep-dish chicago-style
pizza to come out like that to be cheesy
but to still be crunchy there's so many
elements to it to make it right
oh it's just a whole whole process but
one of the main things is having the
right water we took the time out here to
set up our restaurants with the correct
water to meet the standards of chicago
so if our guests notice any difference
it's usually the water even though we
have it set up to chicago style wow
other than that man
finishing a pizza has got to be the
toughest thing i think
i don't know we could take that
challenge yeah i'm up for that challenge
i said the water
at least you'll have some leftovers if
you take it home yeah yeah you have
leftovers on your belly i love it jesse
right and i imagine you guys are looking
forward to this we're looking forward to
talking about the other restaurants
involved in this giordanos is awesome
thanks for joining us this morning jesse
yeah congratulations on making the top
four and thanks for waking up early with
us yeah oh man of course we appreciate
being in this bracket so it's awesome
man it's a great competition for us good
stuff have a good morning yeah of course
we have to remind our viewers so here's
the final four and you can see them here
but uh the final four voting ends
midnight on saturday so you've gotta you
gotta pick your favorite
eightnewsnow.com and we'll see who comes
out on top it's tough though i mean four
amazing restaurants yeah it's